in the mid-1800s a group of
archaeologists from england embarked on
an expedition to mongolia the expedition
was headed by jonathan davis his
long-term research partner jason porter
and their assistant marvin thomas with
them they brought a ship all the
necessary equipment and a team of 10
workers to aid with the dig and the
transportation of any relics back to the
british isles there they found a number
of historically significant artifacts
one of which was described in davis
journal as a most marvelous discovery
the likes of which the world has never
known it will surely be regarded as the
crown jewel of our findings and i
delight at the thought of what ancient
secrets it may allow us to uncover
unfortunately for him he would never get
to find out when the ship arrived back
on the shores of england those waiting
for its return discovered that every
single man on board was dead their
mangled bodies littered the deck of the
ship and jonathan davis's head had been
torn clean off whatever had killed them
it was far stronger than all 13 men
combined given the unusual circumstances
of these deaths the artifacts were
seized by the oddities occult and
paranormal society or oops one of the
many groups started by stuffy english
gentlemen of that era that mainly
functioned as a glorified cabinet of
curiosities and placed in their inner
sanctum the largest and most impressive
of these was a large black stone cube
covered with strange symbols which they
displayed prominently for several years
until one day the same dark force that
killed those archaeologists on their own
ship stirred once more
something escaped from within the stone
killing everyone present in the inner
sanctum and leaving a trail of more
bodies in its wake until eventually it
was apprehended by the scp foundation
placed in containment and designated
scp-076
scp-076 consists of two separate
components a stone cube scp-076-1
and the humanoid contained inside of the
cube or scp-076-2
scp-076-1 is a 3-meter cube of black
metamorphic stone covered in patterned
engravings that have not been matched to
any known civilization analysis via
radioisotope suggests that the cube is
at least 10 000 years old though an
exact date of origin could not be
determined there is a door on one side
sealed with a lock surrounded by 20
smaller locks all arranged in a circular
pattern the foundation has not been able
to locate any of the keys and therefore
is unable to lock the door this is
unfortunate given the nature of the
figure that lurks inside the cube
chained inside of a stone coffin this is
the resting place of scp-076-2
also known as abel abel is a humanoid
male who appears to be in his late 20s
with black hair gray eyes and olive skin
in spite of his youthful appearance his
age is estimated to be around the same
as the cube that holds him his body is
covered in tattoos depicting various
occult icons and images of demonic faces
not uncommon for warrior castes of old
when he is encased in his coffin within
his stone prison abel is technically
dead and registers no vital signs of any
kind however he does not stay dead on an
occasional basis with no apparent cause
he will wake up and reanimate once he is
awake and aware he will attempt to leave
the cube by any means necessary if he
manages to escape he will look for the
nearest human being and attempt to kill
them once he has latched on to a target
he will enter a rage state that will not
stop until he is killed though as his
anomalous nature implies this death is
never permanent and he will always
awaken again eventually terminating abel
in order to stop one of his rampages is
often difficult as he possesses strength
and durability far beyond the
capabilities of an ordinary man he has
superhuman power and speed and though
his physical body can be damaged he does
not appear to respond to pain and
continues to fight through extreme
injuries that would take most targets
down during his time in foundation
custody he has displayed the following
abilities over the course of four
minutes while trying to attack a
research assistant that happened to
cross into his line of sight moments
before he ripped through a reinforced
steel security door with his bare hands
breaking the steel apart as if it were
layers of tin foil during another
incident he was able to run a distance
of 64 meters in under three seconds to
catch up to an armored van filled with
foundation guards while security staff
attempted to neutralize him during the
same incident he took several 50-caliber
rounds to the head and continued to move
and kill for several minutes after in
spite of having literal holes in his
head and missing portions of vital brain
matter during another escape he got a
hold of a piece of steel rebar which he
used to swap bullets from handguns and
assault rifles out of the air like he
was batting a ball with a tennis racquet
during another attempted escape after
killing half a dozen d-classes along the
way foundation staff were eventually
able to trap the entity in a vat of
water sealing the top where he tread
water furiously for an hour before
eventually suffocating this suggests
that unlike most people who will
asphyxiate after only a few minutes
without oxygen he can survive for at
least an hour the most notable of his
anomalous skills however is his ability
to produce weapons usually bladed from
thin air whenever he wants to slow down
security footage has shown that he does
this by pulling the weapons out of a
tiny rift in space a portal to another
dimension of some kind it is unsure
where this portal leads to or how able
accesses it but it appears to function
as his own personal armory stocked with
an endless supply of black non-reflected
bladed weapons which vanish as soon as
they leave his grasp though it is
difficult and often dangerous to do so
able can in fact be killed some
previously affected methods of
termination have included fire from
multiple heavy caliber machine guns
suffocation being crushed between a 13.6
metric ton piece of elevator equipment
cremation via grenade placed inside of a
cavity in his chest and the detonation
of an on-site nuclear warhead every time
scp-076-2 is killed his corpse quickly
decays at an unnaturally rapid rate
until he has turned into a pile of dust
then the door to the cube as well as the
coffin inside will slam shut and the
lock on the outside will rotate shut
somehow abel's body will then reform
inside the coffin this process can take
anywhere from six hours to over 20 years
after a series of failed experiments
containment procedures for scp-076 were
amended to the current procedures in
place
scp-076 is placed in containment area
25b located 200 meters below sea level
tunneled into solid bedrock in an area
with limited seismic activity the only
way to access this area is via an
elevator shaft which is broken up every
50 meters with a reinforced blast door
made of shielding that is 20 centimeters
thick when the elevator shaft is not
being used it is flooded with seawater
the containment area includes an outer
security perimeter outfitted with
security personnel trained in counter
intrusion and close quarters combat an
administrative and support area where
on-site personnel can live and rest a
primary containment zone filled with
seawater and made of a seven meter cube
encased in reinforced material and then
a killing corridor that is 150 meters in
size with an electrical system able to
deliver a 20 000 volt shock in the event
of an attempted containment breach the
security station at the entrance of the
killing corridor must be staffed with at
least three armed security guards at all
times in the event of a containment
breach all staff on site must go to the
closest security station immediately for
weapons and armor the staff will remain
at alert condition 1 until able has been
neutralized and recontained if 90
minutes pass after a full breach without
the order to stand down being given the
entire facility will be flooded with
seawater and the access shaft will be
sealed for 24 hours this is considered
an extreme measure as it will kill any
site staff present but desperate times
call for desperate measures after the
containment procedures were amended and
file updated doctor rejected submitted a
complaint to director maria jones head
of record keeping and information
security administration the
correspondence reads as follows i have
to go on record as saying that i
seriously object to the proposed
revisions of the scp-076 special
containment procedures file i know that
redact all important stuff already
claims it as a security risk but you and
i both know it's just top brass trying
to sweep their biggest and most
embarrassing mistake ever under the rug
omega 7 happened it existed those people
died because you screwed up and you
can't change that no matter how hard you
tried to hide it for god's sake man
those people guarding him deserve to
know exactly what he is and what he did
what we
did how we screwed up so they'll know
better so what was omega-7 what could
have possibly constituted one of the
foundation's worst greatest most
humiliating mistakes ever following the
death of an agent whose identity has
been redacted who had managed to best
able several times in combat the
foundation became aware of an intriguing
possibility whenever abel encountered
the rare individual he perceived as
superior or at least equal to him in
combat his uncontrollable rage would
subside and he would develop a kind of
respect when abel learned of the man's
death he calmed down and was coherent
enough to interview he was distressed at
the death which had occurred as
collateral damage in an airstrike
intended to contain another scp he
explained his feelings on the subject a
man like that deserves to die in combat
so close to his opponent he can feel his
breath not in some destruction ordered
by cowardly kings and princes safe in
their palaces the rest of you you
disgust me i don't even have the urge to
strike you down after this interview the
researcher who conducted it recommended
that the foundation attempt to find a
way to work with abel and somehow
militarize him in accordance with the
beau commission's desire to use as cp
objects for tactical purposes a mobile
task force was proposed referred to as
omega 7 or by its nickname pandora's box
task force omega 7 was to consist of
between 10 and 20 field agents split up
into teams of three and five people each
members of these teams have selected a
roster of highly qualified field agents
and chosen by abel himself their purpose
would be to provide support to him
during high-risk fieldwork and
based situations abel was outfitted with
a device attached to his neck that if it
was triggered or interfered with in any
way would detonate and destroy his
spinal cord trachea and the major blood
vessels of his neck killing him
instantly a tracking device was also
attached to abel in order to keep the
foundation informed of his whereabouts
at all times abel was instructed to
refrain from any unnecessary killing or
violence and only attack when ordered to
this operation was off to a bit of a
rocky start and the head researcher in
charge of it added this addendum to the
initial project proposal for god's sake
find these guys something to do abel's
getting bored and starting putting his
team through live fire exercises they
get bullets he gets training weapons
have you ever seen someone break a man's
jaw using a nerf sword he's not gonna
stop until someone gets killed indeed
abel was getting restless and the
foundation needed to find a way to keep
him busy until he could be occupied with
bloodier pursuits this project report
was submitted regarding abel's
activities in light of
scp-076-2's proficient use of the
sumerian language researchers have asked
it to translate several documents while
it originally replied with disinterest
it has translated some of the documents
it found worthy of its attention most of
the documents chosen by
scp-076-2 were regarding battles or
legendary heroes one of its favorites in
particular being the epic of gilgamesh
however one researcher presented it with
the symbol from scp-073
upon sight of this
scp-076-2 became highly enraged killing
several of the researchers before its
kill switch could be activated when
revived in question about this
scp-076-2 responded aggressively and
that line of questioning was immediately
dropped it is recommended anything
pertaining to scp-073 never be brought
to the attention of scp-076-2
and that the two are never to be in the
same facility eventually the chance to
see omega-7 in action came about enable
and his task force were deployed at the
request of the boa commission though
details have been redacted from the
official file the mission was deemed a
success and general beau thanked the
research team in an email with the
subject line a job well done he wrote
excellent work doctor the mission went
exactly as expected we'll be calling you
again if we need your help this new
chapter of the project bred discord
between the two lead researchers
assigned to abel from here on referred
to as dr w and dr p
dr p was highly in favor of omega 7 and
its military applications while dr w
strongly disproved believing the project
to be an example of the military forcing
the scp foundation to do its dirty work
he responded to the general's
congratulations with a strongly worded
email to his colleague too strongly
worded to repeat here to summarize it
neatly he was very upset following this
email and at dr p's request dr w was
reassigned to scp-682
leaving him as the sole researcher in
charge of the omega-7 project after a
series of incidents regarding friendly
fire and casualties within the task
force itself most of which occurred
during ordinary combat training dr p
sent an email to the general despite our
best efforts subject able is proving
difficult to control all our attempts to
keep him engaged have been more or less
unsuccessful the problem is he's a
perfect killing machine and that's all
he wants to do which seems like exactly
what we wanted but the problem is we
can't seem to turn him off i'm running
out of missions to give him and the ones
i've got left aren't engaging him
mentally he started to lash out at the
other team members it's only a matter of
time before something goes wrong
requesting permission to discontinue the
project and neutralize abel temporarily
until we can find something more for him
to do the general refuse to agree to
this unacceptable neutralizing subject
table at this point is going to cause us
an unacceptable delay we'll have another
mission for you within a couple of weeks
all you have to do is keep him busy
until then send him on vacation or
something dr p was stunned by this
response and unsure how to proceed not
only was there nowhere safe to send abel
on vacation short of firing him into the
furthest recesses of outer space where
he could not hurt anyone he was simply
not a man interested in leisure rest or
vacation as a concept they had let the
tiger out of its cage and now all it
wanted to do was shred bite and kill he
tried to keep abel occupied burning
through d-class on a daily basis that he
could use as human practice dummies but
eventually abel's craving for a
challenge became too strong an automated
alert went out to the staff on the site
where abel was contained signaling the
start of a state of
emergency
scp-076-2 has disabled the explosive
caller failsafe and gone out of control
all staff to high alert further requests
as events warrant there is no surviving
security footage from this incident and
there are no witnesses to recount what
happened next here is what we know for
sure sometime after abel escaped from
his explosive collar containment area 25
began a 10-minute countdown for its
on-site nuclear warhead no staff were
able to successfully evacuate before the
war had detonated reducing the site to
rubble site 67 and 68 activated fema
protocol and secured the location
meanwhile the stone coffin sealed itself
again the lock clicked shut and abel
began to rebuild from almost nothing
ashes to ashes as they say and dust to
dust following this a revised
psychological profile of the entity was
submitted
scp-076-2 either possesses a mind
constructed much differently than our
own or is completely insane with little
empathy or ideas in the way that we
would understand it concepts such as sex
love and equality are completely foreign
ideas to scp-076-2
or at least in comparison to its way of
viewing them subject has shown that it
is completely disinterested in sex
barely differentiating between genders
except as a form of visual
identification also while subject seems
to greatly enjoy the act of killing
causing pain either emotionally or
physically holds no attraction to it
intelligence tests have been wildly
inconclusive when applied to scp-076-2
and no accurate result has yet been
obtained this is due to the fact that no
communication is possible with the
subject when in its rage state subject
displays knowledge of several languages
including english but most notable is
its knowledge of several dialects of
ancient sumerian which seems to be its
preferred language
scp-076 has nothing but contempt for
human beings and will kill them on site
no communication is to be attempted with
the subject now go check out scp-001
dark truth about the o5 council and top
15 most dangerous scp monsters in
containment for more deadly secrets from
inside the foundation